[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis guten Abend und willkommen Rudi
zerne blickt auf den Sport hallo schönen
guten Abend Trauer um Wolfgang Schäuble
er hat die deutsche Politik
jahrzehntelang mitgeprägt Wolfgang
Schäuble ehemaliger cduf Minister und
Bundestagspräsident ist im Alter von 81
Jahren
gestorben hohe Pegelstände an Flüssen
die Hochwasserlage bleibt in einigen
Regionen weiter
angespannt und Niederlagen bei der DZ WM
Martin Schindler und Gabriel Clemens
scheiden aus noch sind aber zwei
deutsche
dabei als Parlamentarier aus
Leidenschaft bezeichnete sich Wolfgang
Schäuble selbst mehr als ein halbes
Jahrhundert lang prägte er die deutsche
und die europäische Politik Schäuble
gilt als einer der Architekten der
deutschen Wiedervereinigung er war
mehrmals Minister war CDU Vorsitzender
Bundestagspräsident und der
dienstälteste Abgeordnete im Bundestag
gestern ist Wolfgang Schäuble im Alter
von 81 Jahren verstorben ein Nachruf von
Andreas
Küst als ihn die Kameras das vorletzte
Mal entdecken ist Wolfgang Schäuble 81
ganz offensichtlich guter Dinge und da
wo er eigentlich immer ist im Deutschen
Bundestag das vorletzte Bild ist nicht
mal einen Monat alt und auch das letzte
zeigt Schäuble im Plenarsaal heute vor
zwei Wochen ein Parlamentarier bis zum
Schluss es gehöre zu seinen Stärken hat
Wolfgang Schäuble gesagt dass er Führung
ertragen könne es war Schäubles
Loyalität die ihn nach oben brachte die
Treue zu Helmut Kohl als
Kanzleramtsminister für Schäuble
geräuschlos Kompromiss herbei als
Innenminister die deutsche Einheit der
Einigungsvertrag gilt als Schäubles
Meisterstück das geordnete Ende der DDR
schäuple verhandelt effizient und so
fair dass ich merkte dass Wolfgang ganze
Reihe von unseren Forderung mit
übernahmen als als sein sich zu eigen
maach der 12 oktober 1990 nach einer
Wahlkampfrede in Oppenau feuert ein
psychisch kranker Mann Schü auf den
Minister ab mein Gott er darf nicht
sterben die Liebe seiner Familie gibt
Schäuble halt aber auch die Politik
deswegen haben m auch die Ärzte von
vorne rein darin bestärkt oder dazu
geraten zu versuchen eben in meiner
politischen Arbeit weiterzumachen und
das hat auch meine Familie überzeugt als
sich die Kanzlerschaft von Helmut Kohl
dem Ende entgegenschleppt will Wolfgang
schäule der ewige Kronprinz übernehmen
aber KL will nicht
die CDU verliert die Bundestagswahl der
neue Parteichef heißt
Schle in der Opposition die
Spendenaffäre nicht nur Kohl auch
Schäuble hat dubiose Zuwendungen
angenommen und weitergeleitet 100.000
Mark in einem Aktenkoffer von
Waffenhändler Karlheinz Schreiber
Schäuble verhättert sich bei dieser
Veranstaltung bin ich an Schreiber
begegnet so das
war's ohne Koffer also ich habe
Aktenkoffer wei ich so zwei Monate nach
dieser Aussage tritt Schäuble zurück
Angela Merkel übernimmt die CDU aber
Schäuble kommt wieder erst als innen
dann als Finanzminister als Minister
schwarze Null der erste der einen
Haushalt ohne Neuverschuldung schafft
Schäuble wird geachtet gefürchtet und
gehasst vor allem in Griechenland dem
Staat dem er mit Rausschmiss aus dem
Euro droht am
2824 Uhr alles unter Kontrolle als
Bundestagspräsident setzt sich Schäuble
gegen die Verrohung der deutschen
Politik ein auch gegen die Verrohung der
Sprache die Art wie wir hier miteinander
reden die kann vorbildlich sein für die
gesellschaftliche Debatte brügeln
sollten wir uns hier nicht die
Geschichte der CDU die Geschichte
Deutschlands und vor allem die
Geschichte Europas lagen Wolfgang
Schäuble am Herzen nun ist er selbst ein
Teil davon
er war ein Glücksfall für die deutsche
Geschichte mit diesen Worten erinnert
der Bundespräsident an Wolfgang Schäuble
wir haben einen großartigen Menschen und
leidenschaftlichen Politiker verloren
der historisches für unser Land erreicht
hat so Steinmeier in einem Kondolenz
Schreiben der Bundespräsident kündigte
einen trauerstaatsakt an viele würdigen
Wolfgang Schäubles politisches Wirken
alexandraacano
berichtet Flaggen auf Halbmast in Berlin
die deutsche Politik sie trauert um
Wolfgang Schäuble ein herausragender
Staatsmann sei gestorben Respekt und
Anerkennung für ein langes politisches
Leben wie von Bundeskanzler Scholz mit
ihm verliert Deutschland einen scharfen
Denker leidenschaftlichen Politiker und
streitbaren Demokraten er habe das Land
mehr als ein halbes Jahrhundert geprägt
ein großer deutscher ein großer Europäer
sei er gewesen so cduchef Friedrich märz
ein
ausnahmepolitiker die deutsche Einheit
die Frau die Freundschaft mit
Frankreich die europäische Politik
insgesamt tragen seine
Handschrift ich persönlich verliere mit
Wolfgang Schäuble den engsten Freund und
Ratgeber den ich in der Politik jemals
hatte für sie war er ein politischer
Lehrmeister schreibt die ehemalige
Kanzlerin über ihn ein Anker in ihren
ersten drei Kabinetten und Wolfgang
schäubler hatte die Fähigkeit weit über
den Tag hinaus große politische
Entwicklungen zu erkennen und zu
gestalten aus Brüssel heißt es er habe
auch als deutscher Politiker Europa
immer mitgedacht Wolfgang Schäuble war
ein
herzenseuropäer für ihn war
Europa die Lösung und die Antwort ähm
auf die großen Krisen Wolfgang schäubler
ein Leben für die Politik das jetzt zu
Ende gegangen
ist und zum Tod von Wolfgang Schäuble
sendet das ZDF ein Portrait im Anschluss
an das heute journal um 22:15 Uhr
Schäubles politische Stationen haben wir
für Sie noch mal zusammengestellt bei ZF
heute und in unserer
App und ein weiterer großer Europäer und
bekannter Politiker ist tot der
ehemalige Präsident der Europäischen
Kommission Jacques Delor Strab heute im
Alter von 98 Jahren in Paris der
ehemalige französische Wirtschafts und
Finanzminister leitete von 1985 bis 1995
die EU-Kommission Delor ebnete den Weg
für eine europäische Wirtschafts und
Währungsunion und trug maßgeblich zur
europäischen Integration
bei zur Hochwasserlage in Deutschland
während einige betroffene Regionen etwa
in Thüringen vorsichtig aufatmen bleibt
die Situation anderords angespannt
besonders an der Elbe die Pegelstände
steigen Dresden bekommt das immer mehr
zu spüren und auch in Niedersachsen und
Bremen ist die Gefahr von Überflutungen
noch nicht gebannt Julia Schröter
berichtet schnell einen Happen zum
Frühstück neue Kraft schöpfen seit Tagen
sind Feuerwehr und THW Tag und Nacht im
Einsatz von weihnachtsruhe keine Spur
wichtigste Aufgabe hier in Liliental bei
Bremen Sandsäcke ranchaffen denn der
flussdeich mitten im Wohngebiet ist
durchgeweicht man hat natürlich
fürchterlich Angst und ja um sein
Eigenheim selst ne und wenn das hier
durchgeht auf Richtung butendig dann
sind wir weg hier ne auch wenn der
Dauerregen aufgehört hat die Anspannung
bleibt erstmal solange das Wasser nicht
abgelaufen ist ein zusätzliches Problem
sind Gaffer
entweder wird auf den Deichen sogar noch
geritten oder es wird mit Autos drauf
gefahren spazieren gehen sowieso also
und das alles schwächt die Deiche
natürlich das es geht nicht also es ist
einfach ein nogogo weiter südlich in
Windehausen in Nordthüringen stehen die
Zeichen auf Entspannung
der 500 seelenort war am ersten
Weihnachtstag weitgehend evakuiert
worden seit dem frühen Nachmittag nun
dürfen die Anwohner zurück in ihre
Häuser doch dort warten in den Kellern
oft böse Überraschungen bei vielen sind
die Heizungen im
Eimer gheizung nagelneue die sich noch
mal eine neue gaseizung dies jah
einbauen lassen haben W wegen wo das mit
dem Gas rauskam die sind hin kein Gas im
Dorf und aktuell auch kein Strom bis
alles wieder normal läuft werden noch
Tage Vergehen während anders wo die
Wasserstände stagnieren oder sinken
steigen sie an der Elbe noch an in
Dresden ist das Terrassenufer überflutet
die Schiffahrt steht still viele dresner
kommen um sich die Wassermassen
anzuschauen sind aber weitgehend
gelassen das ist eigentlich normal für
uns also unter 6 m ist kein Problem wenn
jetzt richtig das Tauwetter jetzt noch
losgeht ja könnte schon der
Scheitelpunkt des Hochwassers wird in
Dresden morgen früh
erwartet soeben erreicht uns die
Nachricht dass der Deich in Liliental
bei Bremen wohl gerissen ist und
angespannt ist ja auch die Situation in
Dresden Anja chal ist für uns vor Ort
Anja wie ist die Lage an der
Elbe ja also wir erwarten den
Scheitelpunkt wir haben es ja gerade
schon mal im Beitrag gehört morgen früh
im Moment ist der Pegel bei 5,91 m und
er verhart bei dieser Marke schon den
ganzen Tag über hier in Dresden gilt
übrigens Alarmstufe 3 die wird wird
ausgelöst bei 6 m und daran sehen wir
schon also sowohl die Stadt als auch das
hochwasserlagezentrum die gehen davon
aus dass die 6 m überschritten werden
wenn der Scheitel morgen erreicht ist
der soll sich sehr lang ziehen also früh
geht's los und man hofft dass es abends
dann vorbei ist steht die Elbe
vielleicht bei 6,25 m bei 6,50 m das
heißt wir sind Gott sei Dank noch weit
entfernt von der dramatischen Lage die
wir hier bei der Jahrhundertflut 2002
hatten als wir ungefähr 9,40 m hatten an
der Elbe und auch 2013 als die Elbe
soari um die 8 m stand die Stadt hat
vorgesorgt die Feuerwehr ist seit Heilig
Abend Tag und Nacht im Einsatz und hat
hier ganz große flutschutzwände
aufgestellt hier am Terrassenufer aber
auch in anderen neuralgischen Stellen in
der Stadt wir haben Glück es hat seit
zwei Tagen nicht mehr geregnet und auch
was das Schmelzwasser angeht das
Tauwasser angeht was vom Riesengebirge
aus Tschechien kommt und vom Erzgebirge
da sieht dass hier in Dresden noch
moderat aus ja wir hoffen alle voller
Optimismus dass Dresden Glück hat und
dass wir mit dem blauen Auge davon
kommen sage ich mal vielen Dank Anja
chal das Extremwetterereignisse wie
Hochwasser mit der Klimakrise zunehmen
davor warnen forschende seit Jahren auch
der Deutsche Wetterdienst zieht eine
alarmierende Bilanz das jetzt zu Ende
gehende Jahr war das wärmste in
Deutschland seit Beginn der
Aufzeichnungen
1881 die Durchschnittstemperatur habe
bei 10 6°
gelegen wer in diesen Tagen krank ist
und in eine Praxis muss hat es mit unter
schwer da gestreikt wird Ärzteverbände
haben bundesweit die niedergelassenen
Praxen dazu aufgerufen zwischen den
Jahren geschlossen zu bleiben damit soll
der Druck auf Bundesgesundheitsminister
Lauterbach erhöht werden die Praxen
seien überlastet es gebe zu viel
Bürokratie und zu wenig Geld mehr von
Frank
Buchwald um seine Patientinnen kümmert
sich Dr Peter Rott einfühlsam und
sorgfältig wenn aber in die Zukunft
denkt wird der Berliner Frauenarzt
schnell unwirsch immer mehr Bürokratie
immer weniger Zeit für seine
Patientinnen rot sagt es
reicht ich verstehe meinen Arztberuf so
dass eine arztptientenbeziehung ja davon
lebt dass ich mit der Patientin Rede und
mich um die Patientin kümmer und nicht
dass ich in den Computer reinhacke so
wie Peter Rott geht es vielen Medizinern
Streik deshalb in vielen deutschen
Städten es fordert leider drastische
Maßnahmen um zu versuchen der Politik
klar zumachen dass so nicht weitergeht
der Bundesgesundheitsminister
beschwichtigt per Kurznachricht die
Hausärzte fordern einen Krisengipfel die
Praxen sind überfüllt es gibt zu viel
Bürokratie diesen Krisengipfel werden
wir im Januar machen Vorschläge zur
notwendigen Entbürokratisierung und zu
einer Honorarreform werden schon seit
Monaten vorbereitet die Krankenkassen
haben kein Verständnis für den
Streik hier werden Brückentage genutzt
die die Patient und Patienten gerade bei
diesem Hochstand an Atemwegserkrankung
dringend bräuchten und was man nicht
vergessen darf ab 1 Januar steigen die
Honorare der Ärztin und Ärzte das heißt
2 Milliarden Euro sind bereits als
zusatzhonner vereinbart Patienten die in
den nächsten Tagen ärztliche Hilfe
brauchen sollten den Notdienst anrufen
unter der bundesweit gültigen Rufnummer
116 117
zum Krieg im Nahen Osten ein Ziel des
israelischen Militärs die Zerstörung des
tunnelnetzes der terromiliz Hamas denn
über Jahre hat die Hamas kilometerl weit
verzweigte Tunnel gebaut für Angriffe
als Waffenlager als Unterschlupf aber
woher und wie bekam die hammas das ganze
Geld dafür Susanna Santina ist der Frage
nachgegangen es war ein spektakulärer
Fund nach Angaben der israelischen Armee
wurden in einem Haus eines Hamas
inab in mehreren Koffern 5 Millionen
Schäkel rund 1,2 Millionen Euro gefunden
und mit jedem Tunnel die die
Streitkräfte in Gasa entdecken wie
diesen bislang größten durch den
Fahrzeug über 4 km fahren können stellt
sich die Frage wie die Heras das alles
finanzieren
konnte weil mehrere Staaten die
Terroristen seit Jahren unterstützen
sagt nizana daschan Leidner so habe die
Hamas jährlich mehr als eineinhalb
Milliarden Dollar zur
Verfügung
fast eine halbe Milliarde kommt von
Qatar zwischen einer halben und einer
Milliarde Dollar von der
palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde mehrere hundert
Millionen Dollar stellt Iran zur
Verfügung und für die Geldüberweisungen
an die Hamas ist nach Ansicht des
israelischen Geheimdienstes vor allem
die Türkei verantwortlich Präsident
erdogan hatte die Hamas Freiheitskämpfer
und Israel einen Terrorstaat
genannt ohne die Türkei wäre es sehr
sehr kompliziert die ham Geld zu weil
das gesamte Geld das nach Gaza und ins
Westjordanland überwiesen wird über die
Türkei läuft über Geldwechsler und
Banken und es erklärt sich auch wie die
Hamas über Jahre ein gigantisches
tunnelnetz bauen konnte gedacht waren
die Tonnen von Zement für Häuser
Krankenhäuser und
Schulen alle Hilfsgüter die nach Gaza
gehen kann die Hamas abgreifen sie
entscheidet was sie
braucht
israel will die Hamas endgültig besiegen
solange sie von vielen Ländern
finanziert werde sei das aber nicht
möglich kennen sie dieses Foto ein
Strandausflug der im Netz ziemlich
bekannt ist und frei erfunden ein Fake
erstellt von einer künstlichen
Intelligenz solche Bilder sieht man
immer häufiger manche Fälschungen sind
offensichtlich viele skuril aber es
entstehen auch immer mehr gefährliche
Fakes ganze Videos die so nie gefilmt
wurden Sven Reen berichtet vom Chaos
Communication Congress in
Hamburg sind das die Tunnel der hamasse
im Gazastreifen sind diese Kämpfer
wirklich am Rande eines feuergefechts um
das gleich zu sagen nein diese Videos
hat Christian bennfeld erschaffen daheim
in Hamburg ohne dass der Mathematiker
dafür seinen Esstisch verlassen musste
aktuell ist die Technik noch sehr sehr
neu um solche generierten Videoclips zu
erzeugen daher glaube ich nicht dass wir
schon viel davon in den sozialen
Netzwerken aktuell sehen aber in der
nahen Zukunft in den nächsten Monaten
werden wir sicherlich eine große
Schwemme erleben Christian benneefeld
nutzt ein öffentlich zugängliches
Programm Open Source in der Fachsprache
die Fälschung zu erkennen ist schwer
beim Durchscrollen in den sozialen
Netzwerken nahezu unmöglich ki-systeme
die solche Fakes erkennen sollen hinken
technisch weit hinterher diese Systeme
achten auf Bildfehler etwa zu viele
Finger oder falsche Körperproportionen
auch ein Abgleich der Farben ist möglich
kommt ein Rotton wirklich in der Natur
so vor mehr als 14 000 it interessierte
diskutieren auch solche KI Entwicklungen
ab heute in Hamburg um Fälschungen zu
entlarfen hilft nämlich noch etwas
Medienkompetenz sprich Aufklärung hier
geht es eben nicht nur um Technik
sondern hier geht's auch ganz viel um
gesellschaftliche Fragen und Technik ist
am Ende eben auch eine gesellschaftliche
Frage sprich nicht alles was technisch
geht sollte die Gesellschaft auch nutzen
angesichts von immer mehr gefälschten
Bildern und Videos ist das aber wohl
auch ein Fall für die Politik doch
Verbote und Auflagen treffen meist nur
kommerzielle Anbieter auch deshalb sind
Grundlagen so wichtig die gibt es auf
dem Kongress in Hamburg schon für die
Jüngsten daneben ein Kunstprojekt das
Menschen erschafft und bei Instagram
hochlädt KI kann eben auch Kunst aber
eben auch entsprechend gekennzeichnet
immer weniger Arbeitskräfte immer höhere
Energiekosten solche Probleme betreffen
die Tourismusbranche in Deutschland wer
Urlaub macht spürt das mangelnder
Service steigende Preise wie sich Gäste
trotzdem anlocken lassen auch und gerade
außerhalb der Saison zeigt ein
Unternehmer in melenburg Vorpommern
Motto warum nicht Homeoffice und Urlaub
verbinden Anna
stadfeld raus aus dem Homeoffice rein
ins gemeinschasbü Hotelunterkunft von
Hannes Trettin in liitzo mobil arbeiten
und die Ostseeinsel Rügen entdecken
diese Mischung nennt der startupgründer
workation sein Geschäft unabhängig von
der Urlaubssaison das steigert die
Umsätze ganzjährig was dabei wiederum
hilft dass Mitarbeiter das ganze Jahr da
bleiben können und nicht nur für die
drei Monate im Sommer herkommen oder in
den Bergen halt nur im Winter da sind im
vergangenen Jahr haben etwa 25% aller
Arbeitnehmer in Deutschland zum Teil im
Homeoffice gearbeitet eine Chance das
Haus fast dauerhaft ausgebucht die Gäste
aus der ganzen Welt dann kommen
teilweise Leute mal aus Vietnam die dann
mal hier sind für eine Woche und dann
sind mal ein paar Leute aus England mal
da oder so natürlich schön dch immer
neue Impulse und da ich natürlich auch
immer kreative Leute auch viel ne ein
Zimmer gibt's pro Monat ab 800 € in ganz
Deutschland sinken die Erträge der
Tourismusbranche obwohl die Preise wie
in Mecklenburg Vorpommern im Schnitt um
10% gestiegen sind der grundar höte
Energie und Lebensmittelpreise und
Personalkosten kreative Wege aus der
Krise sind gefragt Hannes Trettin
jedenfalls betreibt inzwischen
Gemeinschaftsbüros in 25 Hotels in
Deutschland und wir kommen zum Sport die
dazum geht in die dritte Runde und in
London ging es ja wieder richtig hoch
her ja absolut geht um den Einzug ins
Achtelfinale heute und morgen vier
Deutsche waren ja noch mit von der
Partie für die ersten beiden kam dann
heute die Ernüchterung im legendären
Alexandra
die deutsche Nummer 1 Gabriel Clemens
verlor deutlich gegen den Engländer Dave
CHN mit ein
zu4 Gabriel KEM erwischt keinen guten
Tag der Halbfinalist der letzten WM hat
vor allem Probleme die doppelfelder zu
treffen nur 7 von 29 dpfeilen trifft er
zum sogenannten Checkout double trouble
für den German giant Gegner Dave
chissnel zieht sein Spiel souverän durch
und siegt mit 4
setzen im de englischen Duell läuft
zunächst alles in seine Richtung Martin
Schindler aus Strausberg gewinnt die
ersten beiden Sätze dann kommt Scott
Williams immer besser ins Match gleicht
aus und es wird ein D Thriller Schindler
kämpft und doch den besseren Touch hat
Williams der Engländer siegt 4:3 morgen
zwei weitere Chancen für deutsche aufs
Achtelfinale dann spielen Florian Hempel
und Ricardo
pire Jürgen K strahlte sein Team V FC
Liverpool hat dieabellenfrung in der
englischen Premier League übernommen am
zweiten Weihnachtstag gelang ein 2:0
beim FC Burnley morgen kann allerdings
der FC Arsenal an Liverpool wieder
vorbeiziehen wer gewinnt die Trophäe mit
dem goldenen Adler in Obersdorf beginnt
morgen die vier schanzentournee der
Skispringer mit der Qualifikation für
das erste Springen am Freitag die
Hoffnungen auf einen deutschen
Gesamtsieg sind so groß wie lange
nicht Karl Geiger hat 2020 in seinem
Geburtsort Oberstdorf gewonnen in dieser
stehen bisher zwei Weltcupsiege zu Buche
Pius Paschke gehört überraschend zu den
Favoriten mit schon 33 Jahren feierte er
vor knapp zi Wochen den ersten
Weltcupsieg zur Zeit ist der dritte im
Gesamtweltcup sicherlich ist das
Selbstvertrauen wahrscheinlich gerade so
hoch wie
nie aber es hat lang dauert Andreas
Wellinger hat noch keinen Saisonsieg
aber vier Podestplatzierungen und ist
Weltcup zweit wir wollen endlich wieder
Gewinner und am 6 januar um 18 mal wer
es war der Österreicher schffan Kraft
ist Topfavorit hat fünf Saisonsiege und
will den ersten deutschen Turniererfolg
seitdem von Sven hannerwall 2002
verhindern ja das war's vom Sport danke
Rudi schauen wir uns die Lottozahlen an
die Gewinnzahlen lauten 6 9 17 33 41 44
Superzahl ist die 9 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf
lotto.zf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 vorübergehend etwas weniger Regen
und mehr Sonne ist gleich beim Wetter
angesagt von östtin terli um 21:45 Uhr
läuft das heute journal mit Christian
Sivas
[Musik]
tschüss schön guten Abend und Herr
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter ja viel
Regen viel Schnee und dann Tauwetter so
war das Wetter in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten und jetzt wird es erst einmal
etwas ruhiger zwar gibt's immer noch 35
l auf Quadratmeter in der Spitze nach
Nordwesten hin aber nach ostenen z.B ist
es deutlich weniger kein Wunder dass es
so nass war wir hatten die ganze Zeit
eine westliche Strömung und teilweise
kam die Luft auch mal aus Nordwesten und
das setzt sich fort und so müssen wir
mit weiterem Regen recht
in der Nacht z.B nach Nordwesten hin
Regen ansonsten im Süden trocken da wird
es eisekalt bis -2° 9° gibt's ganz im
Westen und morgen liegt diese Front die
wir gesehen haben quer über Deutschland
wandert dann langsam nach Süden und dann
zwischen oberrehein und Erzgebirge dann
regen und ganz im Nordwesten Schauer
dazwischen immer wieder Sonnenschein und
vor allem nach Südosten hin bei
Temperaturen von 6 bis 12° relativ mild
und ziemlich mild geht es auch weiter
Freitag mit weiterem regen
teilstürmischen Wind 7 bis 13° und auch
das Wochenende inklusive Silvester recht
mild und nass schönen Abend